I told you last week that within minutes of
finishing my live stream of the first day
of Trump impeachment hearings, CNN filed a
copyright claim on my six hour livestream,
which I spent all day producing instantly
taking the video offline, instantly cutting
off views, instantly cutting off revenue to
that video.
Now I reached out to CNN and I appealed the
claim and I said, Hey, we didn't use one damn
second of CNN video.
Please release the claim.
And by the following morning, the claim had
been released despite being completely bogus.
We did lose views and monetization for many,
many hours during a key time that people were
interested in that video.
Sad.
But we moved on Friday.
I did another six hour live stream.
And in addition to that day's broadcast, uh,
we did, uh, audience questions on the stream,
the full hearing, so on and so forth.
And it happened again.
But this time it's even worse this time.
It wasn't just CNN that claimed revenue and
blocked the video.
So did NBC news.
Now as a reminder, we did commentary on the
hearings using a C-SPAN feed of the impeachment
hearings.
House of representatives proceedings are funded
by my tax dollars and your tax dollars and
see spans, broadcasts of house proceedings
are in the public domain.
We did not use a single second of NBC coverage
nor CNN coverage.
And yet I get an email from YouTube saying
the David Pakman show impeachment hearing.
Day two has received a claim from NBC news.
This instantly became indistinguishable from
parody and we instantly lose the revenue from
the video we spent all day producing.
Now, of course, I immediately appeal.
I email my YouTube rep, I email anyone I know,
and within a few hours, NBC releases the claim.
Thank you so much.
We can now monetize the video again and within,
it must've been no more than five minutes
of NBC releasing the claim.
I start getting emails from viewers saying,
David, your entire video of that stream and
your commentary has been blocked by CNN on
copyright grounds.
This now has to be a parody, right?
This can't be real.
I'm sure someone just made a Photoshop that
makes it look like the video was taken down.
But Oh, I checked my email and yes, the David
Pakman show impeachment.
Day two has now received a claim from CNN.
What an eye check.
And this time, unlike with NBC where we merely
lost monetization, CNN has blocked the entire
video.
So once again I appeal, I start emailing everyone
I know and eventually it was unblocked.
This is not how this is supposed to work.
Now this time, fortunately this is actually
getting attention.
Reclaim the net, published an article called
David Pakman hit with NBC news content ID
claim on YouTube video containing none of
their footage were good for them.
Reclaim the net, actually wrote about what's
going on where they say, quote, YouTube is
broken.
Copyright system is added.
Again, political commentator David Pacman's,
coverage of today's impeachment hearing against
president Trump was hit with a content ID
claim from NBC news despite the video containing
none of their footage.
Now this is where it starts to get interesting.
This article in reclaim the net led to some
lawyers reaching out to me and of course as
much as they want to help.
This is not easy to fight because this is
how the system is supposed to work.
This is an automatic content ID system that
works for big media against shows like mine
and so many others that you probably watch.
It gives the benefit of the doubt to the computerized
algorithm that supports CNN and NBC and others
and it makes me the little guy have to prove
that I didn't the rules, so again, we're talking
to lawyers.
I'm seeing if we can fight this in any more
systematic way, but in the meantime we're
just going to keep doing what we're doing,
keep signing up on our website for memberships
to make that YouTube revenue as irrelevant
as we can.
175 people.
Thank you.
Signed up for memberships since we got hit
last week and I so appreciate you doing that.
Let's keep it going.
David.
pakman.com/membership memberships are really
cheap.
I won't spend a lot of time on this.
They really help us.
Even if you contribute three bucks a month
by using the coupon code half 19, which saves
you 50% that $3 a month is way, way, way more
than we make from any one viewer on YouTube
that I can assure you, any one viewer, you
know, we make fractions of a cent from on
YouTube.
So you are doing so much good.
Please keep doing it.
I'll keep you posted about anything legal
that we can do or that we choose to do.
But it is very, very ugly.
And um, it is unfortunately, I mean, listen,
all I can do is we've got to do the streams
that our audience wants us to do.
These impeachment hearing streams have gotten
six to 7,000 live concurrent viewers for a
six hour period.
That is a really successful stream for us.
It is highly engaging.
We get subscribers, we get members and super
chat questions.
We're going to keep doing it.
Um, and then if we have to fight for the revenue,
once those videos are archived, I'm ready
to do it.
It sounds like we have people who are willing
to help us do it and we're going to try to
fix the system if we can, but if we can't,
we will work within it and do everything that
we can to keep doing this content and to keep
providing the commentary.
So that's where we are today.
Sadly.
I know it seems satirical.
We had this happen on Wednesday and then it
happens doubly on Friday, but it is what it
is.
I'll keep you informed about how it contenders